hey guys it's YB I'm in Korea it's my
first time being back in ten years I was
born in Seoul South Korea and then I
moved to America when I was 12 and I
came back briefly when I was 14 but
since then I haven't been back the thing
is I'm not in Seoul I'm in Jeju which is
like the island of Korea my parents
moved here and it's actually my first
time being in Jeju I'll do what I do
best eating so I'll show you guys what I
eat on this island and all the
experiences I have so come with me so
for breakfast we went to earth I get in
Korean and fatty baguette - it's a
bakery super popular in Korea I think
there are some in America too but
they're Korean bakeries they had some of
the breads I used to grow up fun this is
one of them see it's like shaped like
Hawaiian bread but inside there it's
kind of like cheese layers in it there's
this pastry with wheat potatoes in it
really good this is my favorite it's
called Swoboda plan it's known for the
bumpy crust and it tastes like peanut
butter this is stuck bulky spicy rice
cake along with fish cake dumplings and
boiled eggs this one also has ramen in
it
Korean fried chicken this one is sweet
and spicy called yum yum chicken this
one is a regular fried chicken called
the food eater and my favorite soy sauce
chicken
it's called had done - Kim they're
crunchy and juicy with perfect amount of
salty and we ate two whole chickens so
tell your toys a volcanic island meaning
it was formed by volcanic eruptions
that's why there are a lot of rocks
everywhere oh you don't believe which is
you - a man in there
Moustafa
[Music]
so I got a guide to learn more about the
rocks it says choose on Julie is a
column shape joint that commonly
develops in Celtic rocks in a lava flow
these tall statues are all overt as you
and her cult tota habiba which
translates into stone grandpa they're
made for me huh mwah
the volcanic rocks with holes my mom
just talked about and are known to
protect Island and also I found out
about this after I posted a picture
hugging one of them people commented
about the statue it's very closely
resembling a penis and apparently
there's a myth that total hottie buns
were indeed shaped after a penis and see
if you rub their nose you will give
birth to a son thanks guys for the info
or pork belly
[Music]
Wow
this is seafood heaven sushi buffet
all-you-can-eat here we are at ham duck
Beach look how clear the water is it's
still a little cold to go swimming but
doesn't stop me from getting in the
water here is like typical which is
spicy octopus octopus on which has
Korean pancakes with octopus and
dumplings they're fried perfectly in
very crispy you can taste the proteins
this is Chi Kok Tsui a traditional
Korean noodle dish literally means knife
noodles cut it's nice and cool soo is
noodle it's made with knife cut wheat
noodles usually two colors white but
this one has mulberry leaf so it's green
Oh blimey
so now we're a totally platonic name
which is how you post national
recreational forest this is actually a
small part of hadassah which is a
mountain in jeju and her lesson is the
highest mountain in south korea for
dinner we're going to be young na which
is apparently really famous for not
girls fishing me which is very uncommon
it's located at a fishing port in Jeju
called both your papa as you can see
there are tons of boats here this is the
famous mackerel sashimi wooden oh hey in
Korean and all the side dishes here
they're right from the ocean for a taste
clean and fresh the plain seaweed and
spy scallions make perfect combo after
the sashimi they give you a mackerel
soup it's peppery spicy and super savory
so my mom and I are gonna go get some
lunch we're gonna go get porridge it's
two in Korean right for the big people
because it helps digestion yeah so it's
good when you're sick but then also when
you're not sick
these are potato skin dumplings and my
mom got octopus kimchi porridge and mine
is called messing each oh nice hanging
is a type of seaweed that's in Korea
that's what makes it green oh my God
look at all this Korean snacks this is
heaven
this is one of my favorite snacks or
even a quick meal pick up kimbap
it translates into triangle give up like
a sushi roll but triangle they sell it
at any convenience stores and there are
many flavors but this one is tuna it's
so good
welcome to a Korean family feast these
are just the appetizer side dishes the
main course is this one they won't touch
which is a spicy fish soup the broth at
the best with light the giant Tower of
rocks over there is weather game which
basically means a lonely rock at 20
meters or 66 feet tall but does look a
little lonely by itself but I think it's
beautiful so today's my last day here
I'm about to go back to LA and I'm
really sad that it's come to an end but
I had so much fun exploring Jeju Island
I learned so many new things on this
island and it was great to get back in
touch with my culture and most
importantly the food was great thanks
guys for coming with me I hope you
enjoyed it and hopefully I can travel to
another country soon so until next time
Korea
[Music]